Hoy les hablaré
sobre los últimos 30 años de la historia de la arquitectura.
Es mucho para cubrir en 18 minutos.
Es un tema complejo,
así que abordaremos solo un lugar complejo:
Nueva Jersey.
Porque hace 30 años, soy de N. Jersey,
yo tenía 6 años y vivía allí en casa de mis padres
en un pueblo llamado Livingston,
y este era mi dormitorio de niño.
En la esquina, desde mi dormitorio,
estaba el baño que compartía con mi hermana.
Y, entre mi dormitorio y el baño,
había un balcón que daba a la sala de estar.
Y ahí todos pasaban el rato viendo la tele.
Así que cada vez que iba de mi habitación al baño,
todos me veían.
Y cada vez que me duchaba y volvía envuelto en una toalla,
Y yo era así.
Era torpe,
inseguro y lo odiaba.
Odiaba ese recorrido, odiaba ese balcón,
odiaba esa habitación y esa casa.
Eso es la arquitectura.
(Risas)
Listo.
Esos sentimientos, esas emociones que sentía,
ese es el poder de la arquitectura.
Porque la arquitectura no se trata de matemáticas, ni de división de zonas,
sino de esas conexiones viscerales, emocionales,
que sentimos en los lugares que ocupamos.
Y no es de extrañar que nos sintamos de esa manera,
porque de acuerdo con la Agencia de Protección Ambiental (EPA)
los estadounidenses pasan el 90 % de su tiempo bajo techo.
O sea, el 90 % del tiempo estamos rodeados de arquitectura.
Eso es muchísimo.
La arquitectura nos determina en formas que ni siquiera nos damos cuenta.
Eso nos hace un poco ingenuos y muy, muy predecibles.
Esto significa que cuando les muestro un edificio como este,
sé lo que les evoca:
piensan en "poder", "estabilidad" y "democracia".
Y sé que lo piensan así por basarse en un edificio
construido hace 2500 años por los griegos.
Este es un truco.
Es un desencadenante que usan los arquitectos
para crear una conexión emocional
con las formas en que construimos nuestros edificios.
Es una conexión emocional predecible;
hemos usado este truco desde hace mucho, mucho tiempo.
Lo usamos hace 200 años para construir bancos.
Lo usamos en el siglo XIX para construir museos de arte.
Y en el siglo XX en EE.UU.,
lo usamos para construir casas.
Miren, estos soldaditos estables, sólidos,
frente al mar, alejados de los elementos.
Esto es muy, muy útil,
porque construir cosas es aterrador.
Es costoso, lleva mucho tiempo y es muy complicado.
Las personas que construyen.
los urbanizadores y los gobiernos,
siempre tienen miedo a la innovación,
y prefieren usar formas que saben que van a funcionar.
Por eso nos encontramos con edificios como este.
Es una bonita edificación.
Es la Biblioteca Pública de Livingston
que se terminó en 2004, en mi ciudad natal,
y, ya saben, tiene una cúpula;
tiene esta cosa redonda, columnas, ladrillo rojo,
que dejan entrever lo que Livingston trata de comunicar con este edificio:
los niños, los valores de propiedad, la historia.
Pero no tiene mucho que ver con una biblioteca de hoy en día.
Ese mismo año, en 2004, al otro lado del país,
se terminó otra biblioteca,
que luce así.
Está en Seattle.
Esta biblioteca muestra cómo usamos
los medios de comunicación en la era digital.
Es un nuevo tipo de equipamiento público para la ciudad,
un lugar para reunirse, leer y compartir.
Entonces, ¿cómo es posible
que en el mismo año, en el mismo país,
dos edificios, ambos denominados bibliotecas,
sean tan completamente diferentes?
Y la respuesta es que la arquitectura funciona según el principio del péndulo.
En un lado está la innovación;
los arquitectos que constantemente impulsan nuevas tecnologías,
nuevas tipologías, nuevas soluciones para las formas de vida actual.
Impulsamos, impulsamos e impulsamos tanto,
que nos alejamos completamente de la gente.
Todos de negro, esto nos deprime.
Uds. creen que nos sentimos muy bien,
pero estamos muertos por dentro porque no tenemos otra opción.
Tenemos que ir al otro lado
y volver a conectarnos con esos símbolos apreciados.
Así lo hacemos, y estamos todos felices,
pero nos sentimos como traidores,
Así que empezamos a experimentar de nuevo;
hacemos oscilar el péndulo de atrás a adelante, una y otra vez.
Así lo hemos hecho en los últimos 300 años,
y claro está, en los últimos 30 años.
Bueno, hace 30 años salíamos de la década de los 70.
Los arquitectos estaban ocupados
experimentando con el denominado "brutalismo".
Tiene que ver con el hormigón.
(Risas)
Eso se puede adivinar.
Ventanas pequeñas, en escala deshumanizante.
Algo realmente muy duro.
Así, nos acercamos a los 80,
y empezamos a incorporar esos símbolos.
Empujamos el péndulo de nuevo en la otra dirección.
Tomamos esas formas que sabemos que gustan
y las actualizamos.
Añadimos neón
y añadimos pasteles
y usamos nuevos materiales.
Les encanta.
No damos abasto.
Tomamos armarios Chippendale
y los convertimos en rascacielos,
que pueden ser castillos medievales hechos de vidrio.
Las formas se agrandaron,
ganaron en audacia y colorido.
Los enanos se convirtieron en columnas.
(Risas)
Los cisnes crecieron hasta el tamaño de los edificios.
Una locura.
Pero eran los 80, eso era genial.
(Risas)
Todos pasamos el rato en centros comerciales,
nos mudamos a los barrios,
y ahí, en los suburbios,
podíamos crear nuestras propias fantasías arquitectónicas.
Esas fantasías
podían ser a la mediterránea,
a la francesa,
o a la italiana.
(Risas)
Posiblemente con un sinfín de palitos de pan.
Esto es lo que pasa con el postmodernismo.
Esto es lo que pasa con los símbolos.
Son fáciles, son baratos,
porque en vez de crear nuevos espacios,
recreamos recuerdos de otros lugares.
Yo sé muy bien, y todos Uds. saben,
que esto no es la Toscana.
Esto es Ohio.
(Risas)
Los arquitectos se sienten frustrados
y empezamos a hacer oscilar el péndulo de nuevo en la otra dirección.
En los años 80 y a principios de los 90,
empezamos a experimentar con el denominado deconstructivismo.
Descartamos los símbolos históricos;
ahora contamos con nuevas técnicas de diseño asistido por computadora,
y nos encontramos con nuevas composiciones;
unas formas que se estrellan contra otras formas.
Esto es académico y embriagador,
y es súper impopular;
Uno queda totalmente excluido.
Normalmente, el péndulo oscilaría de nuevo en dirección opuesta.
Pero entonces, sucedió algo sorprendente:
En 1997, se inauguró este edificio.
Es el Guggenheim de Bilbao, de Frank Gehry.
Este edificio
cambió fundamentalmente la relación del mundo con la arquitectura.
Paul Goldberger dijo que Bilbao fue uno de esos raros momentos
cuando críticos, académicos y público en general,
estuvieron completamente de acuerdo sobre un edificio.
El diario New York Times calificó esta construcción de milagrosa.
El turismo en Bilbao aumentó en un 2500 %
cuando terminaron el edificio.
Así, de repente, todo el mundo quería uno de esos edificios:
Los Ángeles,
Seattle,
Chicago,
Nueva York,
Cleveland,
Springfield.
(Risas)
Todo el mundo quería uno, y Gehry estaba en todas partes.
Él fue nuestro primer arquitecto estrella.
Pero, ¿cómo es posible que estas formas,
salvajes y radicales,
cómo es posible que se conviertan en omnipresentes en todo el mundo?
Y sucedió, porque los medios se galvanizaron en torno a ellos
y rápidamente aprendimos que esas formas significaban cultura y turismo.
Hemos creado una reacción emocional con estas formas.
Lo mismo hicieron los principales alcaldes del mundo.
Así todos creían que si tenían estas formas,
tenían cultura y turismo.
Este fenómeno de comienzos del nuevo milenio
pasó con otros arquitectos estrella.
Le pasó a Zaha
y a Libeskind,
y lo que pasó con estos pocos arquitectos de élite
en el umbral del nuevo milenio,
en realidad empezó a pasar con toda la arquitectura.
Los medios digitales empezaron a aumentar la velocidad
del consumo de información.
Piensen, por ejemplo, cómo consumen arquitectura.
Hace mil años,
tendrían que haber caminado hasta el próximo pueblo para ver un edificio.
El transporte se acelera:
pueden tomar un barco, un avión, pueden ser turistas.
La tecnología acelera.
Se puede ver en los periódicos, en la tele,
y al final, todos somos fotógrafos de arquitectura,
y el edificio se transporta más allá de su ubicación física.
La arquitectura está en todas partes ahora;
eso significa que la velocidad de las comunicaciones
finalmente ha alcanzado la velocidad de la arquitectura.
Debido a que la arquitectura se mueve tan rápido,
no se precisa mucho tiempo para pensar en un edificio.
Se necesita mucho tiempo para construir un edificio,
3 o 4 años,
y en ese tiempo, un arquitecto puede diseñar 2, 8,
o 100 edificios más,
antes de saber si el que diseñó hace 4 años
fue un éxito o no.
Porque nunca ha habido buena retroalimentación en la arquitectura.
Así es como nos encontramos con edificios como este.
El brutalismo no fue un movimiento de 2 años,
sino de 20 años.
Durante 20 años, estuvimos construyendo edificios como este
porque no teníamos ni idea de cuánto los detestaban.
Eso nunca va a volver a suceder.
Creo.
Porque estamos en el umbral de la mayor revolución en la arquitectura
desde la invención del hormigón,
del acero o del ascensor,
y es la revolución de los medios.
Mi teoría es que cuando se aplica el péndulo a los medios de comunicación,
empieza a oscilar cada vez más rápido,
hasta llegar a estar en ambos extremos casi en simultáneo,
y se desdibuja efectivamente la diferencia entre innovación y símbolo,
entre nosotros, los arquitectos, y Uds., el público.
Ahora podemos hacer símbolos casi instantáneos, con carga emocional,
de algo completamente nuevo.
Les enseñaré cómo funciona el sistema
en un proyecto que mi empresa terminó recientemente.
Fuimos contratados para sustituir este edificio que se incendió.
Este es el centro de un pueblo llamado Pines
en Fire Island, en el estado de Nueva York.
Es una comunidad de vacaciones.
Propusimos un edificio audaz,
diferente a cualquiera de las formas a las que la comunidad estaba acostumbrada.
Teníamos miedo y también nuestro cliente.
La comunidad estaba asustada.
Así que creamos una serie de representaciones fotorrealistas
y las pusimos en Facebook
y en Instagram,
y dejamos que la gente empezara a hacer lo que hace:
compartir, comentar, "me gusta", "lo detesto".
Pero eso significó que 2 años antes de que se terminara el edificio,
ya era parte de la comunidad.
Y como los dibujos se parecían exactamente al producto terminado,
no hubo sorpresas.
El edificio llegó a ser parte de la comunidad.
Ese primer verano,
cuando la gente comenzó a llegar y lo compartía en los medios sociales,
el edificio dejó de ser solo un edificio, se convirtió en un medio de comunicación,
porque estas no son solo imágenes de un edificio,
son las imágenes que uno hizo del edificio.
Y conforme uno las usa para contar su historia,
se convierten en parte de la narrativa personal,
y eso hace cortocircuitos
con la memoria colectiva.
Y al cargar estos símbolos, nosotros aprendemos.
Es decir, ya no necesitamos que los griegos
nos digan cómo pensar la arquitectura.
Podemos decirnos mutuamente qué pensamos de la arquitectura,
porque los medios digitales no solo han cambiado la relación entre nosotros,
sino que han cambiado la relación entre nosotros y los edificios.
Piensen por un segundo en esos bibliotecarios de Livingston.
Si ese edificio se construyera hoy,
primero iríamos a Internet en busca de "nuevas bibliotecas".
Seríamos bombardeados con ejemplos de experimentación, de innovación,
sobre qué puede ser una biblioteca.
Eso son municiones.
Municiones que pueden llevar
al alcalde de Livingston, a la gente de Livingston,
y decirles que no hay respuesta única a lo que puede ser una biblioteca hoy.
Seamos parte de esto.
Esta abundancia de soluciones
da la libertad de experimentar.
Todo es diferente ahora.
Los arquitectos ya no son esas criaturas misteriosas
que usan palabras grandilocuentes y dibujos complicados,
y uno ya no es un público desventurado
que no acepta algo que no haya visto antes.
Los arquitectos pueden escuchar,
y uno no se deja intimidar por la arquitectura.
Eso significa que el péndulo oscilante
de un estilo a otro, de un movimiento a otro,
es irrelevante.
De hecho, podemos seguir adelante
y encontrar soluciones adecuadas a los problemas que enfrenta la sociedad.
Este es el final de la historia de la arquitectura,
y significa que los edificios del mañana
serán muy diferente a los edificios de hoy.
Esto significa que un espacio público en la antigua ciudad de Sevilla
puede ser único y adaptado a la medida de una ciudad moderna.
Esto significa que un estadio en Brooklyn puede ser eso, un estadio en Brooklyn,
y no una mala imitación histórica de ladrillo rojo
con base en ideas de lo que debe ser un estadio.
Esto significa que unos robots podrán construir nuestros edificios,
porque finalmente estaremos listos para las formas que van a producir.
Eso significa que los edificios se amoldan a los caprichos de la naturaleza
y no al contrario.
Esto significa que un garaje de estacionamiento en Miami Beach, Florida,
también puede servir para hacer deporte
o para yoga,
o incluso uno puede casarse allí en la noche.
(Risas)
Esto significa que 3 arquitectos pueden soñar con natación
en el East River de Nueva York,
y recaudar medio millón de dólares
de la comunidad unida en torno de esa causa,
ya no es un cliente solo.
Significa que ningún edificio es demasiado pequeño para la innovación,
como este pequeño pabellón de renos,
tan musculoso y fibroso como los animales que se van a observar.
Esto significa que un edificio no tiene que ser bello
para ser amable,
como este pequeño y feo edificio en España,
donde los arquitectos cavaron un agujero,
lo llenaron de heno,
y luego vertieron hormigón alrededor
y cuando el hormigón se secó,
invitaron a alguien a que viniera y limpiara el heno restante.
Finalmente, todo lo que quedó
es esta pequeña y horrible habitación
con todas las huellas y arañazos de cómo se construyó,
para convertirse en el lugar más sublime para observar una puesta de sol español.
Porque ya no importa si es una vaca o un robot
quien construye nuestros edificios.
No importa cómo construimos, lo que importa es qué construimos.
Los arquitectos ya saben cómo hacer edificios más ecológicos,
más inteligentes y más amables.
Hemos estado esperando a que todos Uds. los deseen.
Finalmente, ya no estamos en lados opuestos.
Encuentren un arquitecto, contrátenlo y trabajemos juntos
para hacer mejores edificios, mejores ciudades, para un mundo mejor,
porque hay mucho en juego.
Los edificios no solo reflejan nuestra sociedad,
sino que le dan forma hasta a los espacios más pequeños:
las bibliotecas locales,
los hogares donde formamos a nuestros hijos,
y el paso del dormitorio al baño.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)